>> Martha: DERSOD.
WE HE TO LEAVE THE,
NATHAN.
THANKS VERCH.
LET'SRING IN RETIR GENERAL
KEITH KELLG,ORMER NATIOL SECURI.
GOODO HAVEOU WIT US
NERA KELLOGG.
WANT TO STA WITH PYING
IS FM ANTY BLINKEN FRO
WHER THEYEE THEOVES FROM
TIN MATERIALING RHT NOW.
WATCH TH.
>> EVERYTHG THAT WE'RE SEEI,
INUDING WHAT YESCRIBED IN THE L
A SCENARIO TT IS ALREAN
AY O CATING FALSE
PROVOCIONS.
TH HAVG TO RESPOND TO THOSE
COMMITTING NEW AGGRESSIONL
AGAINSTUKRAINE.
PULLED OUT,VACUATED THE WOMEN
D CHILDREN FRO THE DONBAS
REGI, WHICH THEYAVE A REBELHOLD
UKRAINE.
EY HAVE SAIDHAT UKRAINE IS
OUT  ATTACK TT AREA.
HO DO YOU ASSES WHE WE ARE,
GERAL?
>> YH, LOOK, ANKSMARTHA.
I THK WE'REEADING TO AUN
FIGH
WH I MEAN BY THAT,ETWE
UKINE AND RUSS.
'S CLEAR WIT THE ARRAY OF
FORCES THATUTIN HAS AROUNDUKRAI
ARMYOCAT AUNDKRAI
RIGH NOW AND BROUGHT FORCES
FROM THEAR ET AS WE.
'REALKI PAS EAC OTR.
E DE FOR DIPLOMA IS GONE.
WEEEP TALNGBOUT NA,
TO.
PUTIN KNOWS AT.
TINAS SAID THA HE HAS N
INTEION OF ENGING NATO
HE KNOWS I AUICIDAL EVENT I
HEOES .HE KNOWS IT'SHE END OF R.
HE'S NOTETTI ANYWHER CSE
TO TO.HE DOE'T CARE ABOUTNATO.
HE SAID UAINE IS NOT PT OF
NATO
AN ATTK ON OS A ATTACKN
ALL DOESN'T PLAYO TO.
SO HE KNOWS HE' GOT A FREE CARD
GO FORWD.
ESIDENT BIDEN GAVE H ONE
WHEN HE SAI WELLIMITED
INCURSION MHT B AY.
PRESENT BIDEN SAID NO U.S.TROOPN
THISEFT UKRAINE WE OPEN
THIN DIPLOMACY IS GONE.I THINKO
PA THA PUTIN IS GOINGO G
IN IN A MILITARY INVASI.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM I'VE GOT,
MARTHA.IT'S EAS TOET INO A FIGH
IT HAR TO GET OUT OFONE.SO THE E
IN ERYBY'S MIND SENIOR
DECISION KERS, HOW DO YOU STOTH.
HO DO YOU ENDT IN A Y TT
IS ACCEPTABL TOHE WEST AS
WELL AS FOR RUIA.
OCCUPIER.NG TO BE T
I HEARD GENER KEANE SAYIN HE DO
LENS OF THE UKRNE SHOUL
BE GOI TO THIS MUNICHECURITY
COEREN IN THE CING DAYS
SAID IT' PBABLY NOT A GD
IDEAIVEN RUIA'S PTURE FORHIM TO.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> OH, AH.
NERAKEANE WAS RIGHT.
HE LEES, HE'S NOT COMING BK
IN.
IFHEY START A INVASION
THE'S  WAY HE'ETTI BACK
IN UKRAINE UNLESS IS ON FT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GHT.
THEY WILLONTR ALL OFHE
AIRSPA.
THS NOT AMALL FLIGHT.
RUIA I THE LARST COUNTRY IN
ROPE
RAINE IS T SECOND LARGEST
COTRY INEUROPE.
THESE AREWO LAR COUNTRIES
POTEIALLY INVVED IN CONFLIC
NOTARTF NATO
NATO H TO WATCH TS GO
BEUSEHERE'S NO RECRSE TODO ANYTT
THAT'S WT I MEANY TALKING
ST EACH HER.
THERE' WAYS THATE COU HE
WORKED THIS
BOIDE WERE INTNSIGENT AND
NOBODY WORKE TOWARDSHE MIDDL
GROUND.
AT'S MY FRTRATN.
PLOMACY I SOMETES HA.
U DON'T GETVERYTHING Y
NT.
U M GET AN% SOLION ON
EA SIDE.
BO SID WTED0% A
BECAE OF THAT, I HARDCE
POSITIS BOTH SIDES HE KEN,
YORE HEADING TO FIGHT.
Martha: WE KW FROM
ERYTNG THAT VLADIMIR TIN
HA SAID SINCE 2007,E DOESOT
BELIEVE I THEECURITY
ARITECTURE OF TOSTOLD
WAR.
HE DOESN BUYT ASHE UNITED STATE
THAT'SHE GOA